These days, robots are more common than you might think...
...like this Roomba robotic vacuum.
We wanted to do something simple that people could use every day...
...and that's what inspired us to build the Roomba.
We wanted to be helpful around the house.
Helen Greiner is co-founder of iRobot.
It makes everything from the Roomba...
...to remote-controlled bomb disposal units,...
...to robots that someday might be part of us.
You can have robotics incorporated into your body...
...to give back that arm or leg that you've lost either in service,...
...or through some accident, or disease.
The robots featured at the annual convention of the Association for Unmanned Vehicles International...
...were mostly for military use,...
...but association president Michael Toscano says civilian uses are growing.
Whether it be firefighting, whether it be first responders,...
...whether it be disaster response,...
...unmanned systems allow human beings to be able to do their mission...
...with an extension of their hands, their eyes, and their ears.
Remote-controlled landrovers can detonate bombs or buried land mines.